Big Movies,
genres have life cycles,
they're born,
they become popular,
they exhaust themselves,
and then if they're important enough,
they transform.
Hugh Jackman,
17 year tenure as wolverine.
I think bookends to important milestones
in the superhero film.
Sean to thousands x men directed by
Brian Singer was effectively the start
of the superhero craze that's come to
dominate Hollywood for nearly two
decades and now 2017 slogan directed by
James Mangled represents a response to
the public's exhaustion.
Would that dominance,
if you want to understand how genres
change the writer to look at is
definitely John Qlt who's famous essay
on generic transformation is I think a
good rubric for what's happening in
Logan go wealthy is basically interested
in what occurs when genre conventions
become so well known that the audience
demands something new.
What forms does that change?
Take a look,
wealthy identifies for burlesque
nostalgia,
demythologize nation,
and reaffirmation.
Burlesque is essentially a ridiculous
exaggeration or a parody of genre
conventions.
To Finish Leo [inaudible] quote from the
start of this video,
genres turned to self parody to say,
well,
at least if we can make fun of it for
being infant tile,
that will show how far we've come.
Mel Brooks is of course a master at this
kind of thing and not just for Westerns.
Moments of burlesque can be found in
serious movies too when a trope is made
to suddenly look ridiculous,
undercutting the fantasy with reality
and the superhero genre.
Deadpool film that helped pave the way
for logan is a burlesque through and
through
superhero landing.
So you're going to do a superhero
ladder.
You wait for it.
Superhero landing,
yeah,
that's really hard on your knees,
totally impractical.
They all do it.
Nostalgic films,
the ones that are good anyway,
do more than evoke a romanticized
passed.
They update,
tried and true storylines with
contemporary elements.
They make the audience aware of the
relationship between past and present
qlt sites,
true grit,
but Shane Blacks Kiss,
kiss,
Bang,
fits the bill as well.
A hard boiled detective story in which
many of the tropes are d romanticized,
but the story ultimately follows the
same beats of discovery and heroism.
Hold on demythologize films,
so the most complex of the bunch.
They subject popular myths and
conventions to a reality that undercuts
and exposes them as inadequate or even
harmful weld.
These archetypal example of this is
Roman Polanski,
Chinatown,
a film that follows the hard boiled
detective genre of classic films like
the Maltese Falcon or the big sleep.
Until events become so dark and twisted
and devoid of moral content that justice
has never served in.
The detective is left severely
traumatized,
and another movie like this would be the
Cohen brothers.
No country for old men in which the law
of the new West,
Tommy Lee Jones not only fails to
capture the villain,
but fails to understand him.
I don't want to post bond chips for and
go out and meet something I don't
understand.
The final transformation is the
reaffirmation of myth,
that kind of film that subverts genre
like the Dean mythologize film,
but in the end chooses to reaffirm the
myth not as something that's real,
but it's something that we need to
believe.
I wonder if you could think of a
superhero film that might fall into that
category,
so what is Logan?
Clearly it represents some shift in this
extraordinarily popular genre.
If deadpool signals a self awareness
that the myth of the superhero movie is
losing a bit of it's power,
then I think Logan is an attempt to
interrogate the contours of that myth in
order to see if there are any
interesting directions left for it to
go.
Director James Mangold is a movie buff
and something that's really interesting
about logan is how he uses one genre to
understand another mangled states.
Logan's key theme via a scene from
Shane,
one of the most popular,
and it claimed Westerns of all time.
Matt has to be what it is.
Kept breaking.
I tried it.
It didn't work for me.
Joy,
there's no living with.
There's no going back.
Westerns are really the perfect genre to
measure the superhero movie.
The Myth of the superhero is in many
ways a reincarnation of the myth of the
gunslinger.
Both are heroes who act outside the law
to protect the community at large,
mangled makes these parallels explicit
in a sequence midway through the movie
when Logan,
Charles,
and Laura are taken in by a kindly
family,
the same way that Shane is taken in both
logan and Shane help the family with
work and protect them from greedy
business interests,
but those shane is somewhat haunted by
his life is a gunslinger.
His purpose and the code of laws he
lives by is still necessary to protect
the community.
In the end.
In mangolds version,
the violence that follows the hero can't
be contained far from the valley.
Being saved.
Logan's kindly family is mercilessly and
utterly destroyed,
and if the point wasn't clear,
it's by none other than a clone of Logan
himself.
This is the closest that logan comes to
demythologize.
The whole movie is a meditation on the
violence that all superhero films imply
by earning an r rating,
mangled and Jackman get to show a type
of visceral brutality that complicates
the heroics of Logan's past as well as
those of the x men and all superheroes
like it does.
Shane Logan holds up the romanticized
past of previous superhero movies in the
form of comic books.
You do know they're all bullshit,
right?
Maybe a quarter of it happened and not
let this.
Logan is attempting to expose the
inadequacy of these fantasies,
trying to show that no personal moral
code can wield power without risking
devastation.
This was made painfully clear in the
character Xavier,
who's aging mind it's implied,
may have unintentionally killed a number
of innocent mutants for Logan himself.
The past exploits of heroism from the
other movies,
reemergence as trauma,
nightmares,
and the touching scene with Laura.
Near the end,
he even admits to contemplating suicide.
Actually,
I am
see shooting myself.
Charles said in the end,
Logan makes the final turn into
reaffirmation,
one last act of sacrificial heroics that
reaffirms the myth even after exposing
it as inadequate.
You know,
it makes me wonder if this is the limit
of superhero movies.
It's unclear whether a film that sought
to fully demythologize this myth could
ever really get made or if the genre
itself is even mature enough to handle
such a thing.
In fact,
I think Logan leaves us with these exact
questions.
The movie itself is a conversation
between nostalgia for the genre and are
increasing frustration with its limits.
More than anything,
I'm just excited for what's to come
because it's transition periods like
these,
as qlt might say,
when the really interesting thing.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
Subscribe to this channel for more
videos in this episode was brought to
you by audible.
Audible has a huge selection of digital
audio books,
which I love to listen to when I'm stuck
in Los Angeles.
Traffic for hours and hours and hours.
You might as well make that time
worthwhile.
In honor of the new series.
I'm going to recommend Neil Gaiman's,
American gods as read by Gaiman himself
and a cast of great actors.
It's an extraordinary book and if you go
to audible.com/nerd
writer,
you can get a 30 day free trial and one
free audio book so you can use that on
American gods or something else.
Enjoy.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.